كان لدي 30 عامًا من الخبرة في
عدد لا يحصى من الحروب، وبالنسبة لي،
الوصف هو أنها كانت فيضانًا
وما مررت به في هذه الحرب كان بمثابة
تسونامي، حيث كان كل يوم
أسوأ من اليوم السابق من حيث
الموارد.  أم والطريقة التي كانوا
يتضاءلون بها والعدد المتزايد
للجرحى الهائل بحلول النهاية
35000 وكوالد كان
العدد الهائل من الأطفال 45٪ كانت هناك
أيام كان فيها نصف قائمتي من
الأطفال ولذا يتعين عليك القيام بذلك
أكثر مع يوم أقل في
النهاية عندما كنت في مستشفى علي
كنا المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل في
مدينة غزة، لم يكن لدينا سوى
غرفتي عمليات كان لدينا أكثر من 500 جريح، نصف
العمل الذي قمنا به قمنا بإجراءات باستخدام
التخدير لأننا كنا  نفاد
إجراءات التخدير وأصبح الأمر
مجرد همجي فيما يتعلق بما
كان يتعين علينا القيام به لأنه كان علينا القيام بذلك، وكان علينا
القيام بعملية التخدير وتنظيف الجروح
لأنها كانت تصاب بالعدوى
لأننا لم نتمكن من نقلها إلى
غرفة العمليات ولكن لم يكن لدينا أي
مورفين ولم يعد لدينا أمين
وهو نوع من المخدر ولذا
شعرت كل يوم أنك تغرق
أكثر فأكثر وأتذكر
إحدى تلك الأوقات عندما تحدثت أنا وأنت عن أحد
أعتقد أن الصور التي نشرتها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
كانت عبارة عن خل خرجت به،
وهذا هو حالك منذ عدة أسابيع
وخرجت لشراء الخل بالفعل ولكن كما
قلت عندما تحدثنا على مدار الأسابيع،
تدهور الوضع ويبدو
مما كنت تخبرني به
الأطفال أكثر الحالات خطورة،
الحالات الأكثر رعبًا على الأقل التي
أخبرتنا بها كانت للأطفال، ما رأيته، ما هي
القصص التي بقيت معك
إذا كان هناك واحدة على وجه الخصوص،
أعني أنك تتذكرهم جميعًا ومع
أكثر  في السنوات التي تكون فيها قادرًا
على فصل نفسك عن
الجانب السريري، حيث يتحول عقلك إلى
الطيار الآلي وتقوم بالعمل، ولكن أثناء
قيامك بالعمل، هناك
أشياء معينة تشبه مجرد التهام أحشاءك أو
تلقي لكمة في المعدة.
ترى الضفائر أو
شريط الشعر المرن مع الزهرة الصغيرة،
وتلاحظ طلاء الأظافر للأولاد
مع بطلهم
الخارق المفضل على نوع من السوار البلاستيكي،
وذلك عندما تكون أنت نوعًا ما
أنت أنت، أنت منزعج
حرفيًا، كان هناك صبي
توفي في النهاية، وهو صبي يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا وكان يعاني من
حروق مروعة ومروعة في كامل وجهه
وأطرافه، وبعد إحدى العمليات الجراحية
كان  عطشان جدًا وطلب الماء وجلست
بجانبه وكنت
أعطيه الماء وكنا
نتحدث عن
كرة القدم،
إنه أمر صعب للغاية بالنسبة لك، أستطيع أن
أتخيل جيدًا، لا أستطيع، لا أستطيع  أكذب،
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل أنك طبيب، وأنك
عذراء من صور، وأب أيضًا، وقد
زرت غزة عدة مرات، لذا
فأنت تعرف كيف كان الأمر على مر
السنين تلك الصور وأتذكر أنك
قلت  على بعض العمليات الجراحية
الصراخ الصراخ اه لازم
يبقى معاك الصدمة اللي تقريبا كمان
تحملها من كل شيء أم من
أكثر من 40 يوما كنت في غزة
قدمت مؤتمرا صحفيا أمس
وتحدثت عن الأطفال
عددهم  الأطفال الذين تعرضوا لعمليات بتر الأطراف فقط أخبروا
مشاهدينا بما رأيتم عندما يتعلق الأمر
بإصابات الأطفال وكيف
سيغير ذلك حياة الكثير من الناس،
لذا كان حوالي 40 إلى 50٪ من حمل التشغيل الخاص بي
على الأطفال وكان هؤلاء الأطفال يعانون من
إصابات مروعة لدى بعضهم  كان لدي
بالفعل إصابات مشوهة في الوجه،
العديد من عمليات البتر، لقد أجريت ست
عمليات بتر للأطفال آه في
يوم واحد، كل هذه الإصابات
تغير حياتهم، وسيُتركون مع هذه
الإعاقة الخيالية التي تتطلب
عمليات جراحية متعددة حتى يصلوا إلى سن البلوغ
وواحدة من  أصعب الأمور هو أن بعض
هؤلاء الأطفال هم الناجون الوحيدون من
أسرهم ويقولون إنه ليس لديهم من
يعتني بهم أو عانوا بالإضافة إلى ذلك من
فقدان واحد أو اثنين
من الوالدين ونادراً ما
تجد إخوة آخرين  هل وجدت
إصابة منعزلة حيث
كان بقية أفراد الأسرة سليمين أو عدة أشقاء
أو قتلوا أو الوالدين أحدهما أو كليهما وكان الأمر مجرد
محاولة مختلفة من الصعب جدًا محاولة
نوع ما لديه الطاقة أو الوقت
لتوفير هذا النوع  من الدعم العقلي
الذي يحتاجه هؤلاء الأطفال لأنك حرفيًا
تحاول معالجة مريض تلو
الآخر وقلت إنك تقدر أن
ما بين 700 إلى 900 طفل
قد تم استخدام أطرافهم نتيجة لهذا،
إنه مرتفع جدًا، كان
مروعًا لأن المباني  سوف
ينهار على الناس، وسيتم إخراج هؤلاء الأطفال
من تحت الأنقاض
بأطراف مهشمة، لقد كان حدثًا يوميًا،
كان حدثًا يوميًا يجب عليك
القيام به، هل يمكنني أن أسأل هل يمكنك
العودة بنبض القلب
أم أم  إن إحساسك بالواجب تجاه
والديك هو شيء
تطوره عندما تصبح
طبيبًا وهو ما نسميه
الملكية في اللحظة التي تضع فيها يدك
على مريض، يصبح
ملكًا لك وهذا الوريد، فكيف يحدث
الشعور بالذنب  تشعر بالذنب لمغادرتك ويؤسفني أن
أطرح عليك هذا الشعور
بالذنب المطلق تجاه المرضى
الذين لم تساعدهم، المرضى الذين
تعلم أنهم بحاجة إلى المزيد من المساعدة وتجاه
الزملاء الذين تركتهم
وراءك، ما هو بعد ذلك  في الوقت الذي
تعود فيه إلى المنزل مع
أطفالك، ما هو غرضك الآن،
هل تشعر وكأنني أعرف أنك كنت تتحدث
إلى مات، أنا متأكد من أنني أستطيع الإبلاغ عن هذا الذي
كان فريقي
يقوله، هل هذه شهادة بأنك
تقدم ما هو  الغرض من ذلك
بالنسبة لي أشعر أنني بحاجة إلى القيام
بأمرين أحدهما هو الضغط أه داخل
القطاع الإنساني حتى يتمكن هؤلاء المرضى
من تلقي العلاج الذي يحتاجون إليه
أعني أن هناك أكثر من 30.000 جريح ولا يزال العديد
منهم بحاجة إلى الكثير من العمل  من
بين 36 مستشفى في غزة، لم ينجو سوى تسعة من منظمة الأمم المتحدة من
الأضرار، ثم الجانب الآخر هو أن
يحصلوا على العدالة التي يستحقونها
أه كآباء لكي ننتقل من
هذه الحرب التي قتلت حوالي 7000
طفل واجتاحت  تحت السجادة، فإن
العالم الذي
سندخله حيث تخلىنا تمامًا عن
جميع الإنجازات التي تحققت منذ
الحرب العالمية الثانية فيما يتعلق
بالقانون الإنساني الدولي فيما
يتعلق بإدارة الحرب، هو
عالم مخيف حيث يمكن أن يخسر 7 آلاف طفل
حياتهم ولا أحد
يجيب عليها